[Musica]
ricordo ancora chiaramente quel momento
dopo un lungo viaggio mi sono svegliato
all'improvviso nella notte di rio mio
primo contatto con la città meravigliosa
e stato 13 anni fa quando per la prima
volta da solo e dopo poche ore dall
atterraggio in brasile mi sono ritrovato
nel cuore pulsante della boemia carioca
la lav in quartiere gli artisti e
musicisti dove la festa sembra non
finire mai
[Musica]
e quasi l'alba
ma come un richiamo in lontananza sento
ancora un ritmo di tamburi in quella
giungla di cemento persone sono l'unico
turista rimasto in una situazione
potenzialmente pericolosa ma
l'attrazione per quei suoni è più forte
di me e senza esitare mi dirigo verso la
folla per fare mio quel momento
[Musica]
la pelle dei tamburi vibra come la mia
insieme a quella della moltitudine
caleidoscopica che danza
unità da quel ritmo africano arrivato a
rio sulle navi della diaspora
il canto di resistenza di questa gente
rende così speciale e ricca di umanità
la comunità delle favelas
[Musica]
voglio giocare vai alla l'aia
la rai ha bisogno io la galleria
[Musica]
vai via
si no
[Musica]
l'olanda la mia
da quel giorno ho continuato a
immergermi in quel mondo quasi senza
accorgermene totalmente rapito dalla
magia di quella cultura
un viaggio solitario alla ricerca delle
origini del samba e della batucada che
affonda le sue origini nella religione
afro brasiliana del candomblè gesù e non
ha
[Musica]
o
si no
mi dici
[Musica]
pavia
carriera
[Musica]
sono stato accolto con calore negli
ambienti religiosi musicali l'italiano
il gringo così mi chiamavano
amichevolmente dopo alcuni mesi fa una
volta a borini in un blocco giro e il
pandoro nella rod ag samb praticamente
ovunque andassi era diventato mio
compagno inseparabile notte dopo notte
ho capito il valore della parola
vivenzio imparare a conoscere le cose
attraverso l'esperienza diretta
quotidiana e la profondità dei rapporti
umani sono arrivato fino alla culla di
quelle tradizioni le comunità jeans di
periferia
chi paga oggi del centro storico la
feijoada nelle scuole di samba e le
comunità gis di periferia e anche le
cerimonie religiose dedicate agli ori
chance nel terreno ci candomblè che non
coronare uno dei miei sogni suonare al
carnevale di rio
[Musica]
[Risate]
da tutto questo è nata la mia prima
canzone tu dona morgia è tutto con
l'amore si può fare cioè è uno slang che
sentivo un po ovunque a rio delle fave
nella favela in cui vivevo nei bar ad
ogni angolo della strada nelle feste è
una situazione di entusiasmo quasi una
dichiarazione di fede sì ci sto
lo possiamo fare già esiste
[Musica]
lei dice che non sa bene ma sino ad a1
sia marcisse infausto lo attrae voodoo
mio cuore tanto india è qua stiamo certo
se noi jean una faticata mio faccione
per lustri di tempo caino batucada me
one man show del futbol questa salda
danzanti che non vengono sentirà reti
all amica pretese un sotto ed a cercare
una moto che note del fatto di una
morosa
cos'è il caro che a cupola moggiana
un polmone
dato che va bene
già
si vede
mamma
[Musica]
quindi il bordino
quando
[Musica]
quegli anni immerso tra i veri cariocas
mi hanno profondamente cambiato più di
un'altra cosa mi è cambiato la
commovente l'umanità delle persone che
ho conosciuto soprattutto i lottatori di
ogni giorno le persone che vivono e
lavorano in strada le famiglie i bambini
il popolo delle comunità gis che sono
delle comunità per davvero
vivono in una sinergia totale aiutandosi
a sopravvivere nelle condizioni di
estrema difficoltà per i cosiddetta
paura degrado nel quale versa la maggior
parte delle favelas di rio
[Musica]
nonostante tutte le difficoltà la
violenza i conflitti armati
la povertà queste persone riescono
sempre a trovare un motivo per sorridere
e continuare a sperare in un futuro
migliore
se è vero che se è vero che se
cosa è per te
e tu
femmina
giuseppe ii se metodi surf e liszt
questa è una delle tante canzoni che ho
scritto ispirato a quello che ho vissuto
in brasile e per la quale coinvolto
anche come in tante altre
i bambini dei miei laboratori musicali
che tengo in diversi nel favelas della
città
nella favela del cantagallo a pochi
passi dai lussuosi alberghi di
copacabana
abbiamo creato una canzone insieme con i
piccoli la quale loro immaginano come
vorrebbero che fosse dal loro favela
ideale
dove nella quale poter vivere
serenamente niente più violenza
sporcizie sparatorie ma un mondo
incantato nel quale
poter vivere serenamente fatto solo di
armonia prosperità e pace
[Musica]
cantano galù compagnia ci contavo lui no
alto andrà e cantando kalou compagnia
circondano allora non volta strada e
cantando gallo questo era il titolo
della canzone è così bello poter
condividere con loro un po della gioia e
del potere della musica che appunto ci
regala gioia
regala la possibilità di un'alternativa
positiva alla cattiva strada e alimenta
la speranza dei piccoli e delle loro
famiglie
il popolo brasiliano che lotta duramente
e con grande umiltà conosce il senso
della parola solidarietà e resta unito
anche attraverso la musica e la danza
senza mai smettere di
sfruttare e di sognare
[Musica]
sì lottare e sognare ma durante il
carnevale lo spettacolo più grande al
mondo per il quale questa gente lavora
tutto l'anno per pura passione per poter
vivere quel momento magico nel quale
sentono l'emozione di essere importanti
uniti per creare la bellezza dell'arte
[Musica]
[Applauso]
una felicità effimera
certo forse soltanto un'illusione
cosa importa veramente
vivere per crearsi una sicurezza in un
mondo che non è al sicuro o vivere per
crearsi la possibilità fatta di un sogno
fatto di musica danza e magia
ricercare esclusivamente benessere
materiale rimanendo magari poi soli alla
fine o lottare per sopravvivere ma
restando uniti senza mai smettere di
gioire e di sognare gioire sognare sì
semplicemente perché si è vivi gli occhi
dei bambini immensità
[Musica]
chiara visibilità
l'evento entrate
e profondo sa che la vita ti alzi te ne
vai
attraverso tutto in mano loro
i tagli con la luce e l'ombra
però però però però
[Musica]
canta però però però però il cristo
redentore che mi parla in una stanza
però però però però io mica
[Musica]
e senza scarpe per toccare la città di
rio
la pioggia cadenza la gente ne indica
libertà io tutti a metà però però però
però io mi incanta però però però però
che il redattore che mi volevano stanca
però però però però però però però però
però
[Musica]
[Applauso]
negli occhi dei bambini immensità grazie
mille grazie